whether or not you wanna post political content on your page
on social media is entirely your choice
I know I don't wanna open up my page everyday and see doom and gloom
because there's a lot of it
there's a lot of it and sometimes we need an entertainment reprieve
we need the light so as a content creator
that is entirely your choice
however I believe as a woman and as a mother
your role in society is inherently political
motherhood is political because whether or not you participate in the politics
or the propagandizing of motherhood
your identity is being used to further political agendas
from the left and from the right
and this is not a new thing
society has created this entire identity around what a mother is
all the way back from Mary Magdalene to Florence Henderson
how we depict mothers
and motherhood has always said something about how we view women
and how we view the role of mother in society
just why I talk so much about motherhood
and the identity of motherhood on this page
because it is such a fascinating subject
because you go from being an individual into this archetype
this idea in people's minds
so whether or not you like it
the role of mother once you take that on
is going to politicize your identity
so you don't have to talk about it
but you should be aware of it